هذه واحده من الاف البنايات التي
تحطمت جراء زلزال القوي الذي ضرب المنطقه
الجنوبيه لتركيا مثلما تشاهدون اغراض
ومقتنيات سكان هذه الاحياء لا تزال على
حالها
ولا ندري اين هم من كانوا يملاون هذه
الاحياء بالحياه الاطفال
الرجال النساء منهم من فارق الحياه ومنهم
من غادر المكان ومنهم من وجد نفسه الان
يلتحف السماء في خيمه باقل الامكانيات
السكون الصمت هو وحده من يسكن هذه الاحياء
الان لكن الهزات الارتداديه التي اضحت
قويه وتحولت الى زلازل هي وحدها من تكسر
هذا السكون
لتبدا هذه البنايات الايه للسقوط في اي
لحظه
بالتصدع مجددا ونسمع بين الفينه والاخرى
سقوط اجزاء من هذه البنايات ما يدفعنا الى
الرحيل باقصى سرعه من هذا المكان عبد
القادر خربوش لقناتي العربيه والحدث من
مدينه هاتاي جنوب تركيا